bonjour curieuses et curieux et voilà
c'est la fin de l'été
j'espère que vous avez pu faire des
châteaux de sable et vous balader
tranquillement le long de la plage sur
le sable humide mais avez vous pensé à
regarder ce qu'il se passait sous vos
pieds
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le sable c'est ce qu'on appelle un
milieu granulaire
c'est à dire qu'il est constitué d'un
grand nombre de grains solide sec ou
bénin dans un liquide et ce type de
milieu comme les dunes de sable où les
poudres compactes et des cachets
d'aspirine à des propriétés très
étonnante et très étudiée car il peut
réagir tantôt comme un solide comme en
liquide ou un gage des chercheurs de
marseille ont ainsi voulu mieux
comprendre le comportement de ces
milieux face à un choc ou deux mois et
voici le type de résultats qu'ils ont
obtenus saisi c'est bien le même milieu
une cuve remplie d'eau avec des petits
grains dans laquelle on envoie une bille
alors à votre avis d'où vient la
différence à lundi ce ça bon je vous
explique pour préparer cette expérience
les chercheurs disposent dans une cuve
de petites sphères de verre de moins
d'un millimètre les grains puis ils
remplissent d'eau au m les gras en
suspension
et ensuite ils évacuent l'eau superflu
voilà comment on obtient l'image de
gauche mais dans l'image de droite
les chercheurs ont frappé la cub pour
tasser les grains du milieu non il ne
fera pas comme moi je plante des clous
dans mes meubles ikea chaque coup et
bien étalonné de manière à connaître
exactement le degré de tassement du
milieu et on appelle ça le taux de
compaction donc la différence entre ces
deux expériences c'est que à gauche on a
un milieu meubles et je ne parle pas
d'ikea et à droite on a un milieu
compact et le plus étonnant c'est qu'il
ya seulement 4 % de différence de
compaction entre ces deux expériences
[Musique]
maintenant que se passe-t-il pour que
l'on observe un comportement si
différent entre les deux images lors de
l'impact
le milieu va se déformer sous la
pression de l'objet qui arrive et ça ça
implique de faire bouger le liquide qui
est présent entre les grains dans le
milieu meubles à l'arrivée de l'objet
les grains vont se réorganiser se tasser
et éjecter le liquide vers l'extérieur
ce qui repousse les grains le milieu se
comporte alors comme un liquide
al'inverse quand le milieu et traita
c'est l'impact de l'objet va déformer
l'empilement des grains il s'écarte les
uns des autres ce qui provoque une
aspiration de l'eau sous l'objet cette
aspiration plaint que les gras entre et
rigidifie le milieu et dans ce cas le
milieu répond alors aux chocs comme un
solide
en fait c'est comme quand on marche sur
le sable ça devient dur sous la plante
des pieds et ça fait des bourrelets sur
les côtés
ainsi ce qui va déterminer le
comportement d'un milieu granulaire face
à un choc c'est la préparation initiale
de l'empilement de ces grains meubles
réaction liquide tassé réaction solide
mais pour un même empilement plus le
liquide a du mal à circuler entre les
grains plus la rigidité du milieu est
grande et c'est ce que les chercheurs
ont tenté de montrer avec une deuxième
série d'expériences
d'abord en tassant le milieu autant que
précédemment mais en utilisant des
grains de plus grand diamètre et là il
observe que le milieu est moins rigide
car il ya plus d espace entre les grains
pour que le liquide circulent
puis avec les mêmes grain passé mais en
remplaçant l'eau par un liquide plus
visqueux et là le milieu est plus solide
car cette fois le liquide a plus de mal
à se déplacer
donc en changeant seulement la
préparation du système grain plus
liquides
les chercheurs ont montré qu'ils
pouvaient retrouver l'ensemble des
comportements des milieux granulaires et
en plus expliqué certains risques
naturels la formation de cratères la
liquéfaction des sols
ces travaux pourraient aider au
développement de nouveaux types de
matériaux pour les gilet pare-balles par
exemple voilà donc vous pourrez vous la
péter désormais à l'apéro en expliquant
pourquoi les cacahuètes peuvent se
comporter comme un solide ou comme un
liquide donc ne minimisons pas l'intérêt
de cette recherche car ce résultat c'est
du solide
si vous aussi vous aimez les cacahuètes
abonnez vous